- Thank you.
- I love this outfit.
- Thank you so much.
- I am not kidding.
I am that person that if
you, it's almost like a,
it's a bad thing, because if you come on,
if I happen to like
scroll through something
and I see you, I'm like,
oh, and then I see you.
And I watch the whole thing.
- You're so sweet.
That's so sweet.
- Even if I've seen it.
I've seen The Princess
Switch with my daughter.
I don't know how many times,
and alone, not just 'cause
of my daughter, I love them.
- Well, I mean let me love on you for a second.
- Oh, okay.
- So when I was coming up,
I grew up like doing theater.
- Yeah that's you.
- This has always been a passion of mine
and you were on American Idol and you won.
And I was like, that's it,
I'm going on American Idol.
- What?
- And then that next
week I got an audition
for High School Musical and-
- Well that worked out.
- Worked it, so then I was
like, well nevermind. But-
- That worked out.
- I was like, I'm doing it.
And you were the catalyst.
- Oh, I love that.
- Yeah.
- That's so funny. You are though,
you're captivating.
There's only like a few
people, honestly, in my world,
like of entertainment
that I'm like, must watch.
I can't turn it off.
I don't know why.
- You're so sweet.
- But it's been 16 years
since High School Musical.
Do you remember the beginning of that?
'Cause that was your big first thing.
- I mean yeah like I remember
all the auditions definitely
'cause there were a lot of them.
- Oh really?
- Uh uh.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
There were like three,
but like I remember them distinctly.
- You know the same thing with Idol.
People don't know that
but there were many auditions
before it even got to the TV part.
- Oh yeah, of course.
I like remember meeting
Zac for the first time,
meeting Lucas for the first time.
- Oh wow.
- Me and Ashley had already met
'cause we did a commercial
together like a month prior.
- Random.
- Yeah.
- But it's wild.
The time just keeps flying.
- Yeah, well you started so young.
That's I think that's
what happens when you-
- Yeah like I got decades
under my belt now.
- I know it feels weird.
I feel weird saying like 20 years in a bit
and that feels weird for me too.
But do you ever hear from
like younger kids just now discovering it?
Because my, speaking of my daughter,
my kids actually were introduced
to my nanny as in love with you as well.
So she showed them High School
Musical and they love it.
So do you have like little
kids now coming back?
'Cause you're like, that
was a long time ago.
- I mean, yeah, a long time ago.
- I know what they think, is it weird?
Do they think? 'Cause my daughter,
like she'll see people
and she'll be like, wait,
but is that the same girl?
'Cause they don't get that
it came out like years ago.
- Totally.
- Do you get kids like that?
- I mean, I feel like I
kind of look the same.
Congratulations on that.
That doesn't work for all of us.
- Good genes. Good genes. Good genes.
- Yeah, yeah. It's a weird thing.
- Like it's so crazy because
it continues to live on
like for generations and, but like that's-
- So she was streaming.
- That's like the magic of
musicals though, you know.
Like I remember watching West
Side Story for the first time
when I was like three years old.
And like now there's a new
one for the new generation.
Like musicals, just have
this like legacy about them.
They don't go outta style.
- I think also it has a lot to do.
I mean the story yes.
But also the music is what captivates you
and I know you put out albums
like while you were doing that.
So are you gonna do that again?
I like you singing.
- Thank you. I like singing too.
They like me singing.
- Yeah.
- It definitely, I had
it sit back for a second
and like figure out what
it is that I wanted to do
because like-
- Focus on?
- Yeah. And like, I
felt like if I was going
to do it again
I wanted it to be like
really authentically myself
and like really be my
own voice and perspective
and writing.
And I just like, honestly,
haven't gotten there.
It hasn't been like the main priority.
I feel like if I was to do anything
like a jazz, something
would probably be the first
that comes.
- That's cool.
I love when people do that.
- Because I love this.
- Me too. But I love when people
do like unexpected like that too.
- Yeah. I mean, it's just personal.
Like that's what I listen to.
Like I've always got Julie
London or Billie Holiday playing
at my house and people
are like, interesting.
I'm like, I'm a grandma. I don't know.
- Yeah, I have some
grandma tastes about me too
but I think it's just called good taste.
- Yes it is.
- I think it's just like classic sound.
That sounds good.
- Yeah. Yeah
- I'm just saying congratulations
'cause I hear you have
a new man in your life.
- I do, yeah.
- That's exciting.
That's what, love is fun.
- It's the best.
It's the best when it's like healthy.
You know.
It's really exciting.
- Oh my God, it's amazing.
- It's really beautiful.
- Did you? I know so
he's a baseball player?
So did you know a lot
about baseball before?
- My dad had like brought me
to baseball games when I was young.
- That means no.
You're like I went to a game.
- I love basketball.
- Oh yeah, me too.
- I'm very much like,
go to the sports ball.
Watch basketball.
- Okay.
- Bore ball.
- Sportsball. That's what I call it.
- Sportsball, sportsball.
- Yep.
- But yeah, like I've
definitely grown my knowledge
in baseball.
I know how the game works now.
- You're one ahead of me. Okay.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So wait, so who does he play for again?
- The Pittsburgh Pirates.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- Yeah.
- That's cool.
- Pirates. I like the mascot.
- Yeah. I'm like go Pirates, arr.
- This is how I vote for
things on mascot or colors
or this is how I do it.
So I did my bracket for basketball.
- Oh, nice. You did the bracket.
That's impressive.
- Well I did, okay.
Every single one of my
friends and my sister,
like they all love freaking sports.
Like all, every, like I
don't know how I ended up
in this crew.
Like I am definitely the black
sheep, but they all love it.
So I did a bracket.
I don't know.
- That's impressive.
They tried to get me through
a bracket and I was like,
I don't have time for that.
- Oh my God.
But yeah it's kind of fun
when you start picking teams
for like certain reasons.
But it's not fun when you lose.
- Yeah.
- (indistinct) looking at you Auburn.
Okay. Is there any sport you are good at?
Do you love playing sports?
- I mean.
- Oh that means no.
- Well Cole is like very sporty.
He does all the sports,
loves golf recently got into golfing.
- Golf is fun when you play.
I don't like to watch it.
- And so yeah. I've
recently gotten into it.
That was actually my very
first time at a driving range.
- They're fun.
- Yeah. I realized there's nothing better
than that sound of like the tink
when you hit the ball right.
- Yes.
- I'm like trying to go get fitted.
So I have my own clubs and then feel
like I'm ready to take
on like a full course.
- I kinda get it too.
'Cause like forever, I'd just
be like, that's so boring.
They just like leave
like guys who was here,
like men like leaving and
I'm like, now I get it.
- Now you get it.
- Because you get the
whole freaking day off.
And you're basically just walking around,
talking to your buddies.
- Yeah and we're outside.
- And hitting a ball
around being like, yeah,
I was playing golf.
- Get fresh air,
You're with the trees.
- Yeah.
- Like you go at the right
time of day. You get a sunset.
- Get a drink then come around with them.
- It's a vibe. I'm into it.
- I mean it's a vibe. I'm into it too.
Women, we get, need to catch on.
- We need to go play golf together
that is what we're saying.
- Like, if you can watch I,
this would be good TV as well.
'Cause I'm not great.
I'm like Happy Gilmore.
I can get it down.
Like I can like really nail the ball
but I can't putt for anything.
- Gotcha.
- Yeah.
- Okay. So maybe well, I'm
great at short distance.
You're great at long distance.
Okay, I'm not good at that.
- We can just be one player together.
- Vanessa, what do they call it?
Did I call it something you're
not supposed to call it?
- I honestly have no idea.
- oh, okay. I was like-
- No, it is.
- It is, yeah, the putting, right? Yeah.
- Sports.
- So I drink when I play.
So I'm like, whatever, I'm
not good at that thing.
Putt putt, golf, whatever.
So is it true that you
have a new passion in life?
Are you obsessed with ghosts?
All right here you are.
- It's not really a new passion.
- Okay. We're just finding out.
- You're just kind of like finding out.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
I feel like I've accepted
the fact that like,
I see things and I hear things.
- Wait, do you really?
You've had like experiences?
- Yeah. A lot of them.
- Wow.
- A lot of them over the years,
like even as a child growing up,
like I remember like
getting ready for school
when I was eight years old.
And there was like, you
know, those ducks that like,
is like the duck thing
that you pull to toy.
- Yeah.
- There was one of those
on the dining room table
and I started walking and
it just started like going
alongside me. And I was like, interesting.
And I kind of shut it down for a while
because like it's scary.
- Yeah.
- You know and it' scary. You can't.
- But I recently was like, no,
this is like a gift.
And like something that
I have the ability to do.
So I'm gonna lean into it.
And I recently did my first,
like real paranormal investigation,
like with equipment and everything.
- What equipment? Like a flux capacitor?
Like what are we talking about here?
Like what kind of equipment?
- There's a lot.
There's so much on the market genuinely.
- What?
- But like my favorite thing
is called a spirit box.
- Okay.
And it basically scans radio
frequencies really quickly.
You wanna do it in like
more of a rural place.
So it doesn't pickup stations.
And like, if you put on AM,
it just sounds like static
but something about the
electricity that it creates,
allows spirits to speak
through it and I was-
- I mean, the Earth is all
where you do have frequencies.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Or that's its own frequency, okay.
- So I was sitting at a a tombstone
in a graveyard with my best friend.
- 'Cause that's what we do.
That's worth it.
- Well, if you're trying to find ghosts,
it's like go in the graveyard and-
- Is this at nighttime or?
- Yeah, nighttime, pitch black.
- Wow. We're different.
- And we found this one
tombstone of a spirit
that we were told is very playful.
So I turn it on.
I'm like, hi Sam, I'm Vanessa.
This is Gigi.
I'm like, I'm not very good at this.
I'm like, you're Sam.
- I am so into doing this, wow.
- And then Gigi goes, "Sam,
can you tell us our names?
What are our names?"
And then we just hear, shhh Vanessa. Shhh.
- No, no.
- Yeah.
Did you run then?
- No. No. I was like, cool.
Do you have anything else
that you wanna tell me?
And I just hear, shhh, no.
And I was like, okay, cool.
Well thank you.
You have to like tell them to stay
because you don't want
spirits to follow you.
- Or do you?
- No, you don't.
- No?
- No.
We're trying to live
like you without that.
So we don't need that all the time.
- That's crazy, wait. So if you, okay.
If you were a ghost,
do you think you'd wanna,
I would follow people.
I'd just be nosy.
- I feel like I would be
the ghost that like turns
on Billie Holiday in the
middle of the night.
- That doesn't sound creepy at all.
That old school music.
- I love it though.
I love creepy.
- I do too.
It's a good, well creep.
We just, it's one of
our favorite songs so.
- Yes.
- Okay. Wait.
I have to talk about this though
because you're here to talk
about this and I love this.
So you have your own clothing collection
and it's with Fabletics, right?
- Yes, yeah.
- Okay. So tell us about it.
So is this important to you?
You like-
- Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah. It's-
- I like comfort.
- Yeah. I really do too.
I've always been like a fan of Fabletics
for their quality and the affordability
and spring is like my
favorite time of the year.
It's like, you're getting out in the sun,
you're going to the beach.
Like you'll maybe like
working out a little bit more,
getting ready for summer.
- If I was promised I'd look like that.
I would do it. Yeah.
- But yeah. So I wanted
to do like a full lifestyle collections.
So there's stuff in there to work out in.
That's like really
comfortable, but super cute.
There's a bunch of terry cloth pieces,
like in shorts and pants, little tops.
My favorite is like this terry towel dress
with a peep hole
that there's like a
sports bra built into it.
So like you're supported
but it's like really cute
and chic and you dress well.
- I like how it's comfy.
It all sounds comfy too.
- Yeah.
It is all very comfortable.
- I'm into that.
- That's the name of the game for me.
- Amen. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Well, we have something for
everyone in our audience.
Fabletics has grown to become
one of the most beloved
and inclusive, active lifewear brands.
So they're also known
for its high fashion,
high performance designs
at accessible prices,
which is nice for everybody.
Today, you're all going
home with a $200 gift card
to shop Fabletics.
- And hopefully you'll look
like her in them
'cause that was real cute.